[Musique]
le regard un peu fou de vincent van gogh
projeter ainsi sur ses écrans géants est
une invitation à voir différemment
l'oeuvre de ce grand peintre du 19e
siècle ce gigantesque
ça ressemble un show qu'est-ce que je me
trouve c'est plus compliqué qu'un show
rock quand on s'installe pour un show
rock on arrive le matin
quelquefois la veille ici ça fait deux
semaines que des équipes de 20 personnes
travaillent presque jour et nuit à
ajuster
[Musique]
l'installation baptisé imagine van gogh
utilise 50 appareils pour projeter dans
une grande pièce des oeuvres aux
couleurs de la provence
créée pendant les trois dernières années
de la vie de l'artiste néerlandais
on est vraiment dans une exposition
immersive où vous avez mêlée pour
photographier des images retrouvées sur
internet
on est vraiment dans l'exposition 2.0 là
tout à fait oui mais je crois de toute
façon que cet accès à la vidéo
projection permet vraiment aujourd'hui à
cette nouvelle génération d'avoir accès
à la culture
enrobé de musique classique des gros
plans de près de 200 oeuvres défilent en
rafales et sans description pendant 30
minutes
dans cet espace 2 arsenal art
contemporain
ici vous n'êtes pas dans un musée
classique vous êtes dans une exposition
immersive
vous n'êtes vous n'êtes plus en distance
par rapport à l'oeuvre de vincent van
gogh vous pouvez toucher la toile vous
pouvez marcher dans cette exposition
vous pouvez même courir vous pouvez
sauter jouer à la marelle en europe ce
genre d'installation immersive et très
populaire il y en a aussi sur les
oeuvres de gustav klimt de claude monet
et de picasso
ce concept de projection de toile sur
écran géant n'est pas la tasse de thé de
la directrice générale du musée des
beaux-arts de montréal
en aucun cas ces procédés multimédia
sont équivalents à des oeuvres d'art ce
sont des divertissements
c'est impossible de d'imaginer que ce
type de 18 fication de l'oeuvre d'art
puisse remplacer l'expérience réelle
l'émotion réelle que nous avons quand on
est face à l'oeuvre elle même à montréal
plus de quarante deux mille billets ont
déjà été vendus pour imagine van gogh le
producteur québécois veut maintenant
faire voyager l'installation et on dit
que j'avais la présente à québec comme
adjoint oui on finalise sa dans les
prochaines heures et on souhaite
commence à québec qu'à la mi juin
ici louis fait depuis mai radio-canada
moria
[Musique]